ce week-end les chéris ça n'était pas un
week-end comme les autres et oui c'était
l'anniversaire d'une personne que
j'adore que j'aime par dessus tout qu
une personne qui m'aiment et que j'aime
il s'agit bien sûr de jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et j'en ai
j'ai j'ai un cadeau pour vous mais
jean-luc j'ai vraiment un cadeau pour
vous je vais vous d'offrir jean-luc une
croisière en escale aux îles et wendy
hill et il est en dessous non ce n'est
pas ben tiens voilà c'est ça donc jean
luc voilà je vous le dis bah je loue moi
même c'est une croisière sur la seine
avec la personne de votre choix sur la
scène
oui merci les gars